what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 2 of the reinforcement learning
series as well as part 2 of doing cue
learning in this video we are hopefully
gonna finish this agent and we will have
it traversing up a mountain in no time
so where we left off we initialized our
cute table but the cute table just has
random values and now we're ready to
actually start updating those random
values to hopefully meaningful values
and having great success getting up this
mountain so the first thing I'm gonna do
is just kind of clean up these print
statements we don't need them here and
they're just kind of creating clutter
now I'm gonna add in a couple of
constants the first one is gonna be
learning rate and we're gonna say zero
point one here this would be anything
from zero to one now 0.1 is kind of low
but you might actually decay a learning
rate here just like you might with your
typical deep learning applications for
now we're just going to keep 0.1 keep it
nice and simple no decay for that the
next thing we're gonna do is we're going
to add a discount and this will be zero
point nine five now the discount is kind
of like a weight you know how it's a
measure of how important do we find
future actions so in this case we're
going to say zero point nine five and
you'll see in a little bit when we
actually start to write our new Q
variable function or algorithm what
everyone call it how discount comes into
play there but basically it's a measure
of how important or future actions over
current actions basically or future
reward versus current reward because the
way the agent works is it's always going
to go off of the max Q value well if
your max Q value is always looking ahead
to future max Q values as well that's
gonna back propagate all the way down a
long chain this is basically 0.9 5 times
0.9 five times 0.9 five so that's gonna
go on a long way down a chain so anyways
it's a measure of how much we value
future reward over current reward and
it's a value between zero and one
let's discount we're also going to throw
in episodes and we're gonna say well
have 25,000 episodes we need quite a few
episodes for
this agent to learn but don't worry
twenty-five thousand episodes doesn't
actually take that long as long as we're
not rendering every single one of them
so now we have our cue table now the
thing that we need next is the NV dot
reset as well as the action here when we
take a step that returns to us this
likes these states but the states are
these continuous states and like I was
saying before we need to actually
convert those continuous States to
discrete states so we need a quick
helper function that's gonna help us do
that so we're gonna say define get dis
discrete state and we do that by passing
a state and then we're gonna say the
discrete discrete underscore state is
equal to the current state minus the
environment dot it's the observation
space dot lo divided by the discrete
observation space window size then we
want to return this in tuple form so
we're gonna return a tuple form of that
new discrete state dot as type and we're
gonna make it a numpy int so this will
give us a nice discrete state and the
first way we can test that really
quickly is actually I'm gonna take this
end reset from up above and I'm gonna
cut it and I'm gonna paste it actually
down a little bit here and we're going
to start off our discrete state as being
equal to get discrete States m dot reset
so even though the m dot step returns
four values
m dot reset just gives just returns the
initial state to us so so yeah so we can
just pass it right into there all right
so now I can print discrete state
save that we can run that and we can see
that starting discrete state is a seven
and ten and then what we can do is we
can actually look up that discrete state
so for example we could say Q table and
because it's a tuple we can actually
index by tuple so you know you could
index you could say 7 or something but
we can actually pass the discrete state
itself and let's go ahead and print that
copy-paste and you can see here these
are our Q values are starting Q values
so they're just random and meaningless
but if we wanted to go off of the
maximum one we would just say n P dots
Arg max Q table here paste and we see
the the Arg max was actually the zero
with so we want to go with action zero
so okay pretty cool so that's how we get
the the max value so now I'm gonna do is
just kind of clear these outs and cool
so now we're ready with this new
discrete state we can actually take our
first action and then slowly start to
generate new Q values so I'm gonna
actually uncomment out this looping down
here we still want to stay start with
we're gonna start with done equals false
and then now rather than action being
hard coded as a - we're gonna say action
equals I shouldn't have to lead it that
other value but whatever may be a [ __ ]
max Q table and then we index it by that
starting discrete state but later it's
going to get changed
so we'll get a new discrete state soon
enough but for now we have our action
then new state reward done Lola is still
is an action and then we also want to
get our new discrete nudists
State we want to get that new discrete
state because we're actually gonna use
that in our formulation of the Q values
so we get the new discrete state as
being get discrete state for the new
state we don't any longer need to print
those rewards but here we can act we can
do the render and then we're gonna say
if not done because this the environment
might actually be over so if it's over
we don't want to do anything but if it's
not over so if not done we want to say
max future Q is equal to NP max not Arg
max but max because in this case we're
gonna use max future Q in our new Q
formula so we actually want that Q value
rather than what's the Arg max so we're
gonna say n P dot max a Q table and then
we just index that Q table by new
discrete state in this max future Q soon
will be we will multiply that discount
to the max future Q and that's why we're
gathering this and that's how slowly
over time future actions get back in
their rewards I submit not really reward
like the reward gets back propagated but
really it's the Q value gets back
propagated down that down the table so
this is really where all the magic
happens anyway max future Q we get that
max value we also want to grab the
current Q value so that's just going to
be a Q table Q table and in this case we
can slice it by doing new Q table
the current discrete State yeah and then
plus the action so we just kind of add
this little tuple to of this so we're
slicing it by this state here the
discrete state which is a tuple so this
is you know say a 20 by 20 and
the action so we're getting the exact Q
value so as opposed to if we just did
discrete state we would get three values
in this case we're just getting the Q
value so we get the current Q and now
comes the actual Q formula which will be
equal to and this is what this is and
hopefully this is the last time you ever
have to look at this again anyway that
is going to be equal to 1 minus the
learning rate learning rate I don't know
why it didn't Wow
why it doesn't want to autocomplete for
me maybe because I don't know
anyway 1 minus the learning rate and
then times whatever the current Q value
is plus the learning rate times the
reward that we got reward plus the
discount times the max future Q so this
is the formula for calculating all Q
values and the way it back propagates is
based pretty much purely on these values
here where yes we do get a reward for
things but we really only actually get a
reward ever for completing this entire
thing otherwise the reward is always a
negative 1 so really it's only once we
finally get a future Q that finally
things will start to back propagate and
kind of you know you'll get one
completion and then after you get the
one completion you're more likely to see
another completion and then and then
that just kind of snowball effects
basically so anyway there's our new Q
and then once we have the new Q value we
just need to update our Q table with
that new Q value so we would just say Q
table for that discrete state plus the
action that we took now we want to
update that as with the new Q value so
just take note and record
and pee es close attention that we're
updating the discreet state after we
took the step of that discreet state
okay so we took the step we've received
reward for this thing already we have
this new state but based on this new
state that we got and the reward and all
that we are now going to update that's
that action that we just took so as you
know discrete state as opposed to using
the new discrete state let's say okay so
if not done that's what we do but if we
are done the environment either we took
200 steps and we just suck and we didn't
get anywhere but we might l if new
underscore state 0 so we have position
and we have velocity if that is greater
than or equal to the environment goal
underscore position then what we want to
say is Q table and then discrete state
plus the action we want to set that
value to be zero and so that's our
reward for completing things you know
just nothing just no punishment you're
welcome
and then and then that's basically it so
then we just discrete state equals new
discrete state and the loop goes on and
on and on so with that let me go ahead
and run Q learning too and let's just
make sure we don't have any errors up to
this point is he cute he's so cute okay
now now that we've done that we actually
want to iterate over episodes so this
only runs one time and that's not really
useful so now we would want to say
basically
here for Epis episode in range episode
zoo we want to do this cool so then we
should add something to the tippity-top
where we kind of display some metrics
now I think probably in the next
tutorial we'll dive a little deeper but
at least to start it would be useful to
know sort of where we are from time to
time so I'm gonna add another metric
called show show underscore every and
we'll say we'll say 2000 so every 2000
episodes let just like let us know that
you're still alive and you're doing
things right so for episode in episodes
if yes we'll just say if episode modulo
show every zero so basically if we can
divide the episode number by 2000 and
the remainder is zero then what we want
to say is we'll say render equals true
else we'll say render render equals
false also let's just print episode
episode and then we'll come down to
where we render and we'll say if render
then render and this is because actually
rendering the environment is really slow
otherwise we can actually run through
these environments really really quickly
so I closed it that's okay cue learning
- let's go ahead and run that real quick
see what we get
so this is our starting environment not
very good and then we'll continue
running through and I'm not gonna go all
the way but we'll just kind of go some
distance for now
why this didn't disappear
I guess maybe once we get to two maybe
once we get to 2,000 steps or episodes
also that's spring really slow I would
have figured we would have 2000 episodes
by now anyway yeah he's already getting
better I was expecting to have to show
you one more likely parameter that you
would almost have to have but he might
actually succeed I wonder if we just got
lucky also we should have been printing
if we reached our objective and we
didn't do that oh yes Wow by 4000 steps
he's already made it so so now what I
want to show you guys let's go back I've
got a few things I must show you even
though we've already solved the thing I
guess this is just such a simple
objective let's print print an F string
and we'll say we made it on episode and
then we'll just pass episode so let's
save that rerun that and let that start
to run and we'll kind of see how long it
takes to start getting some victories
here cool and while we wait shouts out
to some of my mouth he already made it
oh he's just he's killing it he's
already made it by a hundred episodes
he's now he's making it every episode
incredible this is actually news to me
and then by episode by episode mm he
should solve it ooh
it looked like he was solving it every
episode I wonder why he's actually not
solving it anymore is that not every it
looks like it's every episode
one two three four it sure looks like
every episode of me let's see what
happens on Episode four thousand recent
members I will get back to you in a
moment this is so fascinating I can't
believe he's already made oh my goodness
so every time I guess he's gonna make it
now the question is is he always gonna
take that long so I'm not sure you
actually have to swing up and back and
then up and back again every time
curious very curious like if you just
swung up back and like I think that you
could make it quick or anyway back to my
most recent channel members brand new
members circe Roca the dragon 573
Jesse's still well in Kyle gummy thank
you all very much for your support
welcome to the club of amazing people so
it looks like that time it did go a
little quicker and the quicker you go
because it's it's it's a negative one
every time at every frame so if you
could find a quicker way to achieve the
objective that would be superior
I almost makes it but ok so very
interesting I didn't think that that I
was gonna make it by episode 200 let me
just try that one more time see if he
makes it again by episode boy was it 2
or 300 I think I mean it was so fast it
was so fast today was solving this
environment yeah 200 oh my gosh so you
can see like it takes a little bit then
once he starts finding it's a there's
like snowballs in and then soon it's
like every episode he makes it pretty
cool actually how quickly that worked
I'm kind of surprised
yeah he's already really good okay so so
this is actually strange that he was
able to make it that quick because we
actually need one more thing usually and
it's called Epsilon and it's a random
it's a measure of how much random this
you want to do or how much exploration
you want to do because I don't want to
talk about this in the next video I'm
just just slap it on even though we
somehow achieved this objective that
quickly what I'm gonna do is what
[Music]
hopefully not that okay so we're gonna
add a couple so we're gonna say Epsilon
and we're gonna say that is equal to I
guess I'm going to start at 0.5 I'm just
going to start it kind of small and this
is gonna be the chance so again epsilon
would be as between 0 & 1 the higher the
epsilon the more likely we are to just
perform a random action and exploratory
it which is just fancy for random and
then over time what we want to do is we
want that model to stop exploring so
even though our model has actually
solved this I believe I can't remember I
think if you just go up a little bit and
then swing back as quickly as possible
I think you can achieve the objective a
little quicker and the in is in this
case more advantageous to solve it
quicker but once this model has figured
out one way to possibly do it it's never
gonna come back
so so to start off I'm thinking we'll
have some randomness here and then some
some some environments will just simply
require random actions to be taken to
even be solved once and then also some
things some things you like ways to
solve something you would never think of
the agent can find out because you've
allowed it to do these explore it
exploratory moves anyway enough and then
so we'll say we'll start at 0.5 then
we'll say start epsilon Epsilon
underscore decaying
um this is actually kind of curious I
we're gonna play with this I think in a
future episode anyway and Epsilon nope
you jerk how did stop it and and why are
you oh that that's how you're gonna okay
and Epsilon I don't know about that uh I
don't uh sure about that that level of
autocomplete it's like well it has an
Ian entity in it I'm gonna say episodes
divided by two and the double div is
like Python to type division right where
it will always divide out to an integer
so we don't have a float okay so now
what we're gonna say is the amount that
we wanted to K by each episode we're
gonna say is epsilon underscore decay
underscore value equals epsilon I hope
this video is not like an hour long
already anyway and epsilon decaying -
start what you don't want okay you don't
want to autocomplete that because it was
touching subtraction anyways epsilon to
K value great okay now we're gonna go
down to the very bottom
after the discrete state update and then
just one tab over so a per episode
update what we want to ask is if at if
end epsilon decaying is greater than or
equal to the current episode that we're
on but it's also in the episode is
greater than or equal to the start
epsilon decaying if that's the case
we're gonna say epsilon minus equals
epsilon to K value save that and we'll
run that and something tells me
it's probably not gonna learn all that
great but now I'm actually I'm super
curious I could have such a hard time
waiting to the next video that I
probably won't even wait I part of me
wants to like start the decay on episode
mm like once he's already solved the
environment then be like alright now
take a lot of random actions and then
see does he learn to solve the
environment like way quicker yeah I feel
like that's super inefficient I feel
like I feel like he could go just barely
up and then go back and then be good and
I think that's kind of what we're hoping
epsilon could get us to I just don't
think it's gonna happen unfortunately
you almost need maybe we do need a
really high starting epsilon I don't
know anyway I think that's probably
something we should focus on on the next
tutorial because this one's probably
super long see how inefficient that was
if he was allowed to have continued he
would have made it to the flag he he
understood yes it's a he he understood
how to get to the flag it's just he
didn't have enough time we cut him off
because were jerks but he would have
made it I'm just gonna look at a couple
more you guys are free to leave any time
did you
I just really think maybe if it goes up
I don't know maybe maybe this is as
efficient as it could possibly be I
don't know anyway that's all for now
questions comments concerns whatever
leaving below come hang out with us in
discord GG / centex if you want to
support the content you know the deal
that beautiful blue button it's calling
your name begging cool yeah in the next
tutorial we'll talk about how to do some
more stuff like this is one very very
basic way to debug what's going on but
in the next tutorial we'll talk about
how to start kind of generating our own
metrics that we can kind of start
looking at because I think time to
completion and typically you know oh
that was so wonderful that was the most
efficient solution yet
hold it hold on everybody hold on I I
think I saw what I was talking about
what I really wanted to see that was so
perfect I hope I didn't miss him like
swinging back and you all are like what
is he talking about
ah like I think that's what he did the
first time he like just barely swung
back the perfect amount oh that looked
so good I've got it now I'm gonna have
to go back to the video and see if it
actually did that cuz that's the perfect
solution right there
ah man I'm spending way too much way
through long I'm Way too excited about
this mountain and car thing I just it's
so cool and I'm such a nerd okay so the
next time alright quick and unfortunate
update totally forgot like we calculated
epsilon we decayed epsilon but we never
actually used Epsilon and I don't want
to have to talk about this in the next
video because we're actually just
supposed to be analyzing things so I'm
gonna fix that so where we actually
decide on our action this is where we
actually want to decide whether or not
to use Epsilon so what we're gonna say
is if NP dot random dot random this
creates a random float between 0 & 1
if that is greater than whatever our
epsilon value is as long as that's
greater we want to actually do actions
in the usual way otherwise we actually
just want to do a random action so we're
say action equals NP random dot R and
int and we want that ran int but weensie
row and m dot action space and then the
number of actions so now if we do that
and I set epsilon well we can leave it
at 0.5 and it probably won't learn as
quickly so let's just rerun this real
quick hopefully we don't see it's
learning by episode 200 anymore
and we also I'll make sure it at least
learns but and then but at this point
like this is kind of where you want to
start tinkering with these various
values so okay so it starts learning at
more like episode 1200 or so and the
benefit here is that we're actually
still doing some exploration because as
soon as it finds one way to the flag
it's just gonna like super optimize very
quickly for that way of getting to the
flag when there might be a better more
efficient way to get to the flag but as
long as it's found at one time without
any exploration without any randomness
it's always just gonna kind of optimize
that one path and for many tasks maybe
that's okay with you but in the case of
like the mountain car for example like
that what we just watched was like super
inefficient but so so the goal is to
make it efficiently anyways we'll talk
more about kind of tinkering with values
and statistics and stuff in the next
tutorial but just how to make that
change so I'll see you there